so we need to have just like a very real
and honest conversation today about the
reality that Donald Trump just always
gets his ass kicked
internationally by everyone and I don't
like it and I want to know whether you
see it my way and whether this is
something you're concerned about and I'm
not talking about any kind of delusional
my framework for this is not some hyper
nationalist the US needs to always come
out quote winning at the expense of
every other country I want us working
together with the international
community I want to solve serious
problems in productive ways as as an
alliance of countries but what I mean is
why is it that Donald Trump is always
the loser in negotiations often
negotiations he shouldn't be
participating in always the
laughingstock always the guy that the
adults in the room often aren't even
inviting into the room anymore because
his presence is so pointless and
counterproductive that's what I want to
talk about today it is embarrassing that
the president can't stop getting his ass
kicked
day in and day out it's it's boneheaded
stupidity and I'm going to give you some
examples there's lots of good ones by
the way
in a recent DailyKos piece which I
recommend you check out by Lawrence
Lewis which was posted to our subreddit
Donald Trump as an example is now
considering jumping into a fifteen
billion dollar french bailout of Iran if
Iran is willing to come back into the
Iran nuclear deal a be back in
compliance with the Iran nuclear deal
there are people so out of touch with
reality that they see this as Donald
Trump being the big strong negotiator
but this is maybe the most ignorant ly
myopic view of international relations
and specifically of the Iran deal than I
can imagine remember Donald Trump bailed
out of the Iran nuclear deal
even though Iran had been in compliance
ever since the deal was signed it was an
international embarrassment for the
United States to just not stick to our
agreements without anyone else having
violated them why would we not stick to
our side of the deal the other countries
including France
had to try at the g7 to salvage what was
potentially left and one of the things
that they said was okay if the US is out
we get that it's logical that you might
try to start researching nuclear
technology and developing it and it
could potentially be used for weapons
what can we do to keep you in compliance
and one of the things they came up with
was a $15 French a 15 billion dollar
French bailout which now Donald Trump is
considering participating in because he
wants Iran to be compliant with the
nuclear deal this is only a conversation
this is only on the table because Trump
bailed on the nuke deal to begin with
for no reason whatsoever just getting
his ass kicked
getting it kicked internationally
another obvious example is North Korea
we're going to talk more about North
Korea later on in today's program Trump
is so desperate to be liked and so
overconfident in his negotiating skills
that he doesn't even realize that
there's this long history of North
Korean leaders manipulating the United
States are trying to manipulate the
United States and Trump goes and meets
with Kim jong-un no preconditions pranic
plenty of pompous bluster comes out
thinking that he negotiated some
incredible deal that no one else has
been able to do even though it was the
same promises that the Kim family has
been making for decades claims victory
and then of course nothing happens and
meanwhile North Korea nuclear and
weapons development just keeps going on
ballistics missiles missile tests Trump
getting his ass kicked internationally
again one more example I think you're
getting the sort of gist of it the
Chinese trade war Trump thinks I'll
throw some tariffs at China they'll
buckle down the US will win however he
defines that never mind that he doesn't
even understand how tariffs work he
doesn't understand how the us-china
relationship works and China instead
says okay you're putting tariffs on us
we'll put tariffs on you we'll get our
aluminum and our steel elsewhere we'll
make a deal with Russia for energy
development and exploration we'll get
our soy elsewhere and Trump gets his ass
kicked again
crushing farmers
crushing related industries and the
world is just wondering what is this guy
doing why is he doing this could we
maybe not have a president getting his
ass kicked weekly and I've been very
careful when I make a comparison between
Trump and George W Bush I don't want to
do it in any way that suggests George W
Bush was anything other than a
neoconservative maniac with terrible
policies Bush didn't get his ass kicked
in this way internationally week in and
week out Bush made terrible policy
decisions I disagreed with his moral
framework based on born-again
Christianity or whatever it was that he
most recently ascribed to he was a war
monger economically I didn't agree with
the guy but he wasn't getting his ass
kicked in the boneheaded way that Donald
Trump is week in and week out our
historical allies are looking around
wondering what's wrong with this guy
it's not just that they disagree with
the decisions or the underlying policy
to the extent Trump has an underlying
political philosophy they just can't
understand why he keeps doing the most
boneheaded things to his own
disadvantage and it's reflecting
extremely poorly on the United States
the world you know the the Trump may
have high approval among red-state
Republicans 55 plus I'm sure among that
group his approval rating is off the
chart but the world is wondering how
could Americans be so dumb and this is
the way they're thinking about us now
how could they be so dumb as to have
voted this guy in in the first place we
need to change that in November of next
year and I hope that we will